i challenged a thousand people to
photoshop
this image an idea that's completely
original and i didn't steal
from small-time streamer ludwig uh so
don't even look into that those are
fake allegations you know all that kind
of stuff hold on let me sorry
let me get on y'all's level okay sorry
tall guy problems over here
uh let's bring up the subreddit shall we
guys it is
a sub reddit day guys coffee cell
underscore gg that's coffee's alliance
for gg
join the small club honestly it's a
small club
of privileged people right now who
photoshopped this image
so we're gonna see what you guys have
highest voted meme at the end of this
wins
platinum award and a feature in next
saturday's video
i will also be selecting my personal
favorite to also receive platinum
okay if it's terrible if it's good
whatever anything that makes me laugh
and then finally stay to the end because
i'm going to be announcing next week's
challenge so if you want to win
imaginary internet points that don't
matter to anyone else
but about a thousand people who know
this thing exists hey
you've come to the right place welcome
to the subreddit guys
uh honestly we're going pretty fast a
thousand members already we need to bump
those numbers up
10 000 would be nice uh but you know
we're growing we just started last week
okay give me
cut me some slack so let's get into it
first meme
what is this coffeezilla after missing
an upload hey man
no this is not gonna happen guys this is
never gonna happen
i honestly i saw always marco i don't
know if you guys saw this guy uh a
friend of mine
he recently shaved his head and it's not
a good look
i really i joined his stream and i
realized immediately this cannot happen
to me so we are not going to be missing
an upload
daily youtuber all the way through
january maybe february we'll see
but not going to happen so i gave that
gold yes because i'm
i'm a giving man next meme by the way
some of these memes if it doesn't have
the photoshopped image in it it's
technically
not up for competition but i thought
we'd just look at the memes of the
subreddit anyways
okay the story i tell
what actually happened
dan pina's like stabbing a teddy bear
then he's on joe rogan the next day
being like joe
it was eight feet tall and it was about
to kill me until i
killed it okay
i guess that's a chuckle i'll upvote
that why not you know
a lot of memes that are not part of the
competition this is the first thing
actually i learned about my audience
y'all don't listen
that's number one these are
irrelevant memes but they're pretty good
honestly spoken like a true laptop
lifestyle millionaire
a 30-year harvard education whoa
this is worthless
that's what caleb maddox believes that's
what a lot of these guys believe they're
like
30 years at harvard it's a waste of time
it's
why would you even do that i mean it
reminds me of this stuff dude it's like
it's not just
caleb maddox who's pushing this whack
idea the most obsolete idea
is go to school get a job work hard save
money
robert kiyosaki dude terrible idea don't
listen to that guy
the most obsolete idea is to get a job
guys hey
you don't need a job you can chill gold
and so get rich advice like robert
kiyosaki guys
sell for mlms do that guys try that on
for size
greatest opportunity of our era so uh
gave that gold
and i'll go ahead and give that an up
toke all right next meme
business okay again not relevant to the
competition but okay
that's fine business gurus be like
having a
stable nine-to-five job with robert
kiyosaki hustling 24-7
and not actually making money i'll take
it
i'll upload it give it gold uh see i'm a
generous
you know dictator over here in the
coffee zilla gg subreddit you gotta join
guys
because i'm very nice to people next
meme
top tips not relevant many of the
youngsters asked me how i became so
successful so here are my top tips
buy a big house to impress investment
bankers befriend investment bankers
get investment bankers drunk learn
inside information off drunk bankers
trade off inside information very simple
good good advice actually nah first time
we've had pretty good advice on this
subreddit so far
the real pandemic at home diy
nice okay you get gold for that me mom
can i get a harvard education
mom you can have a harvard education at
home the harvard education at home
it's kind of true isn't it man uh this
is the new
they're pitching themselves harvard
educated it's like these guys are snake
oil salesmen
this is not even clo it's not even close
this is like how amish says he
he went to harvard x harvard
x it's not the same thing guys
not the same long time no see friend i
haven't seen in years
me pyramid scheme
yeah uh this kind of hits close to home
but this
if you ever get a text or facebook
messenger it's usually facebook
messenger
out of the blue don't respond from
someone you haven't seen they're like
hey man
so nice to see you done in a long time
no see got a
crazy business opportunity yeah i really
want to talk to you about got time for
coffee
no you only got time for coffeezilla
next meme okay finally someone uses a
picture of me
but it's the wrong picture of me you had
photo you had green screen material and
instead you
you took a circle of me
i don't know what this kind of photoshop
is but anyway okay first photoshop
whatever when steven said get free gold
from posting on his reddit he minutes
the greatest opportunity of our era true
guys true actually i didn't mean that
anyone who joined would get free gold
but
that's how everybody interpreted it i
meant everybody who was on the reddit at
the time
of me putting up that video got free
gold but everyone came looking for free
gold so
i ended up uh scamming you i don't know
what else to say i tried to give a lot
of free gold away but
nonetheless if you actually go to my
subreddit right now the number one
uh top top rated thing is
impeach coffee when you post a
competitive
coffeezilla subreddit three days ago and
didn't get the gold that was promised
i did a promise going away to everybody
i don't think i did i was trying to say
that everyone who was on the separate
pre the announcement got free gold and
it was going to become harder to get
over time
but i okay i scammed you guys what can i
say everyone came
to the to the subreddit like uh the
seagulls from finding nemo
boomer references
anyway what's the meme but didn't get
the goal that was promised
hours of business man doing business
guys i get you got to do the business
to get the subreddit followers that's
all that it is
in fact look here's a new competition
for you guys to get gold because the
current offer is off the table
now if you want to get gold if you bring
in three friends
you get gold if you have three people in
your downline and if those three people
also get three people they get gold and
if your three friends do that
you get platinum that's an announcement
hey
we're a pyramid scheme now i think it'd
be really funny so get three friends in
if you can prove it and you can prove
that those three friends got three
friends you get platinum that's it
that's it that's how it's done
announcing it right now and don't worry
you won't get scammed remember how i did
the last giveaway
so don't worry about that i never
scammed anybody in my life
oh they actually used the thing they
used the green screen
i didn't even notice 25 up votes okay
uh did that beat the other guy no
the guy who actually did the thing
okay all right oh here we go
coffee zilla got a pee this is what i'm
talking about yes
yes they did the thing coffeezilla got a
phd in fake gurus they use the green
screen beautiful
mwah wow i love it dreams phd
harvard astrophysicist yeah guys i
i have an announcement to make i'm the
secret expert
astrophysicist he was talking about i'm
an expert in statistics and he didn't
cheat guys
he didn't cheat uh yeah nice
clever used uh you know used a callback
is that the top voted one right now
let's find out
i think that's the highest upvoted one
so far 36
upvotes all right way to go
you're on your way to platinum sir uh
you
whatever i don't know what that username
is next meme guys it was hard to find a
picture of dan pina smiling
coming to the sub to support your
favorite youtuber
coming on the sub to receive a gold
award
wow he actually is smiling i think that
is the first time i've seen dan pina
smile
you know a lot of dan pedia memes he's a
very memeable guy
i've got to give it to him he's one of
the most memeable gurus for sure and i
did give you gold okay notice that
i'm not a con man i came through on my
promise
okay came here for the reddit gold
that's it and as you can see
not a con man i gave you reddit gold
okay because right now people are
demanding that i i scammed everybody
dude
i seriously gave golem to as many people
as i could but you guys
too many of you posted what could i say
i demand coffee to be
investigated by himself on his own
channel for not giving me the gold on
the meme i posted three days ago
where's my gold sifu scammer of the year
time
it's actually pretty good i just noticed
he used the thing
five upvotes too bad buddy not gonna get
gold this time
now you know what actually since you
actually did the thing
hey i'm gonna give you gold boom how
dare you slander this great man
true also gold thank you
for defending my honor
appreciate it bud appreciate you
defending my honor there
gold a tough choice what do you choose
joining harvard joining maximum wage
i can't decide guys what do you think we
should do
entrepreneur join my team for 20
and be your own boss too everybody on
instagram
with like 4x in their bio or
entrepreneur in their bio
they don't own what they say they own
please guys don't fall for this stuff
there's gold
and then there's maximum gold real gold
coffeezilla oh very good well hey sir
you've got real gold right there
fool's gold maximum comedy gold
worth more than 30 years at harvard oh
yeah that's uh that's gonna be a meme
forever i feel like
i have a feeling this is gonna turn into
people making fun of me wheeze for being
a hobbit and for having a large
head idk coffeezilla 2021
therapist coffeezilla with glasses isn't
real he can't hurt you
coffeezilla with glasses hey hey man
you don't need to stretch out my head
that's rude that's already offensive
this is fake news guys don't believe
this i don't know where you got this
image but uh i do not wear glasses
perfect 20 20 vision and don't let
anyone tell you guys otherwise please
coffee zilla exposing upcoming fake
gurus for the first time
oh gee fake gurus first time
uh yeah man sometimes i do look at these
like new guys coming up and i'm like
how do you do not see where this leads
it's a bad it's a bad
slight decision not because of me but
just look at the future of like
do you want to be tai lopez when you
grow up who who grows up and be
is like hey i want to be like dan lok i
don't i don't know
i don't know who looks up to these guys
coffeezilla taking a dump on his
king-sized toilet
10 million dollar studio stuff what is
what is this photoshop you couldn't crap
it in to make it like seem like i
just didn't have no feet you wouldn't
understand
and then by the way okay that was all
fine fun and games but then the comments
isn't that a normal sized toilet with a
hobbit on it
you're right i need to slap whoever
wrote the title for spreading fake news
what is this okay let me say something
guys i'm sorry i gotta address this
right now
okay this is this is downright offensive
i'm gonna put this to bed once and for
all this has all been fake news this
whole time
the truth is guys i'm not that short
okay um
i'm actually pretty tall my doctor
measured me the other day he said i'm
one rogan tall
maybe even two like i'm like one to two
rogans tall
and um yeah i don't want to be made fun
of it for it anymore i know the hobbit
meme was funny but
uh it's not funny anymore
okay i'm out here trying to fight the
fake gurus and
y'all are fighting y'all are bullying me
and i don't appreciate that
all right guys that about does it the
highest rated meme
that used the challenge was this one
coffee's like a phd in fake gurus dreams
phd harvard astrophysicist
congratulations
you're the first person to get platinum
on this subreddit and uh yeah
hats off to you sir congratulations it's
a special day
okay gold and platinum that's a
it's a big big honor okay the next
person i guess
runner up i would have to say this one
coffeezilla after missing an upload sir
you also get platinum thanks for playing
this is why you always have to just try
because you never know if you're gonna
what you're gonna win
okay here on coffeezilla easy to get
gold and platinum
especially if you recruit through
friends so guys thanks for playing
thanks for joining
uh i hope you enjoyed it you know i i
guess back in my day i had saturday
morning cartoons you guys
have lazy saturdays lazy red saturdays
good trade-off i would say
uh so thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed but before you go
we got a new challenge for the subreddit
this week guys
it's not a meme now we're getting our
musical talents engaged
all you have to do is create the new
lazy saturday
theme song guys the highest upvoted
theme song
uh and it has to be safe for work you
know fun
good for the video but it will become
our theme song and we'll also get
platinum so
submit your theme songs in the subreddit
guys we'll have a little uh
form for it or whatever go ahead sign up
who knows you could win you could win
gold you could win platinum
and better yet you could win the love
and support
of a bunch of internet strangers thanks
for watching see you the next one
[Music]
you